en marge du traumatisme visible des
attentats du world trade center new york
a aussi ses victimes
oubliée la crise économique qui a suivi
le 11-septembre a en effet entraîné des
vagues de licenciements depuis quelques
mois dans manhattan
on voit réapparaître des sdf la ville
n'avait pas connu cela depuis plus de 20
ans jean marc pitte christian de carnets
sur place c'est ici que j'habitais avant
le 11 septembre
voilà la société où je travaillais comme
vigile avant la catastrophe du 11
septembre
c'est la première fois que david lopez
se retrouvent à la rue parce que
l'entreprise pour laquelle il
travaillait comme veilleur de nuit avait
de nombreux clients ou trade center elle
a compressé son personnel à 38 ans et
deux jours après l'attentât contre les
tours jumelles
il s'est retrouvé sans emploi c'est moi
dans mon uniforme de militaires depuis
son départ du corps des marines david
n'avait fait qu'enchaîner les boutiques
vous payer sans économie et sans aide il
a dû abandonner son logement
je n'ai jamais pensé que je deviendrais
un sans abri j'ai servi mon pays je
pensais qu'on prendrait soin de moi
qu'on me donnerais mon dû au début ça
marchait et après j'ai dû faire des
pieds et des mains pour réclamer ce
qu'on me devait et ça continue
davy n'est pas le seul dans son cas ils
sont des milliers de travailleurs
précaires à avoir ainsi basculer dans la
pauvreté depuis un an ils ne sont pas
morts n'ont pas perdu de proches
mais ce sont pourtant des victimes du 11
septembre
ils n'ont pas reçu tellement dead il
n'était pas aussi directement touchés
que les familles des disparus se sont en
quelque sorte des victimes de seconde
catégorie
parce que l'activité économique est
affecté leurs emplois disparaissent
lisez leur est très difficile d'obtenir
des aides car on ne le considère pas
comme des victimes à part entière durant
les années 90 le nombre des sdf à new
york avait progressivement diminuer la
récession entamée début 2001 a commencé
à les faire réapparaître la catastrophe
du 11 septembre a considérablement
aggravé cette tendance nombre le nombre
des repas servis ici par notre
association a augmenté d'environ 26% et
le nombre des sans abri a new york a
explosé depuis un an
oui on n'a pas vu un tel phénomène
et puis je devais tout début des années
difficile d'estimer précisément le
nombre des sdf de new york
les vingt sept mille recensés dans les
abris de la ville ne représentent qu'une
minorité
la plupart préfèrent dormir dehors par
refus des règles par crainte de
l'insécurité qui règne dans nombre de
ces foyers
ils leur préfèrent le froid la pluie et
la terrible indifférence de leurs
concitoyens les gens observent ils se
demandent pourquoi tu dors dans la rue
alors que tu pourrais dormir à l'abri
quelque part ne doivent pas leur aide
noda qui regardent de haut voilà tout